[Music]
on this Friday night intensifying anger
over the police shooting death of an
indigenous woman in New Brunswick I
pissed them out reached grief and
growing demands for justice for Chantal
more Canadians take a knee for George
Floyd and call for an end to systemic
racism here we can grow we can be better
in the u.s. police are pushed for
answers why was that necessary
Global News investigates collisions and
kickbacks the alleged scheme between
some police officers and tow truck
operators and a star is born
the ten year old Canadian with the
astonishing voice
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
in cities across this country Canadians
are making their voices heard in a
powerful display of unity against police
brutality and systemic racism a big
crowd has gathered a jack pole plaza in
Vancouver and from Halifax to Toronto
and in Ottawa thousands filled the
streets in solidarity with the protests
in the US and to make the point that
black lives matter in Canada - in the
u.s. protests are stretching into a
second weekend the wave of outrage
sweeping across the country after the
death of George Floyd under the knee of
a white officer here on Parliament Hill
thousands gathered to stand in
solidarity before marching through the
streets Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
took part in it - and took a knee our
Abigail Beeman is in the midst of it all
tonight
Abigail well Donna it's a very large
rally by Ottawa standards thousands and
thousands of people came out to show
their support there are still thousands
of people here behind me at the human
rights memorial another thing unusual
for Ottawa businesses boarded up in
advance of this demonstration something
we haven't seen in recent memory but
everything here stayed peaceful and
that's
organizers intent all along people we
spoke to said they came here because
it's important to send a message that
things need to change that racism needs
to end and that they want a different
and better world for their children
here's what some of them had to say
really moving it's just like seeing that
like not everyone's bad and just like
how people do want to stand up and make
a difference it's just like who's like a
man who can't see is in the blind this
is what you choose not to I just feel
like everyone should know that there is
problems in our society today at the
same time I feel like this together to
make it happen I make everything we feel
like this what we're doing today is a
lot bigger and we can worry about both
it like after but this is a really big
issue that needs to be cited over
obviously people to understand that we
are people too we have hopes we have
dreams our color is not a weapon we are
who we are and we're proud to be who we
are we will stand in these streets day
and night to be heard now a lot of the
faces we saw in the crowd today were not
black and that's important to note
because there was some discord among
organizers and some other black
community groups here in Ottawa they had
some concerns over safety and also some
koban 19 concerned and so a message went
out to the black community here in
Ottawa not to show up for today's event
there was also opposition to police
being in attendance the Ottawa Police
Service is aware of that community
pushback but said it's their job to give
a space for people to grieve and to be
heard and to do that safely the police
officers I saw in the crowd were taking
a knee along with demonstrators so still
thousands of people here they just took
a knee again a moment ago lots of people
trying to take some copa90 safety
precautions wearing masks as examples
but many people we spoke with said that
the that racism is as much of a concern
if not more important than this health
pandemic Donna
all right Abigail Beeman in Ottawa thank
you thousands of people also took to the
streets in Toronto today to show
solidarity with Americans as Eric
Sorenson explains they're calling for
change in this country - the March was
large and it was peaceful in Canada's
biggest city store
weren't taking chances but the
participants were almost universally
determined to send a non-violent message
but racism does exist and must be
addressed I believe that in this moment
that it is a perfect storm we are all
paying attention maybe because of kovat
19 but certainly because of George Floyd
and the horrific things that we
witnessed on social media and on the
television screen and you know to say
enough there's nothing simple about
organizing such a demonstration these
days the pandemic is still with us and
social distancing did not seem to be
carefully observed here certain advocacy
groups for blacks took a pass on
supporting this event and some are
critical that police were included in
the planning still Toronto's Police
Chief and other officers took a knee to
show solidarity what we hope will be a
lasting platform for change through
peace and communication between the
community members and our civic leaders
for some marches here are not just in
solidarity with what's happening in the
United States but reflect the unique
history of race relations in this
country in Canada the issue is broader
you cannot address race in this country
and not include the treatment of
indigenous peoples
it's literally once a week we hear about
an indigenous person being brutalized by
a police officer and so for decades
we've had a problem with anti black and
anti indigenous racism by police for
blacks in Toronto the relationship with
police is strained there are practical
proposals to outfit officers with body
cameras to make sure that we are doing
everything we can to fast-track body
cameras for all Toronto police officers
but it will take time to establish trust
I have a twin brother who actually had
cops invade his house and put guns to
his face and totally be way too violent
Eddie Stewart says blacks in Canada
still do not experience the Equality
other Canadians take for granted in this
multicultural paradise nah we're not
there yet we are so not there yet
there's so much more work to do
other marches are happening across
Canada over the weekend to raise
awareness that racism individual and
systemic still exists and the Canadians
first have to accept
then push for change Eric Sorenson
Global News Toronto the police shooting
of a 26 year old indigenous woman in New
Brunswick has raised all kinds of
questions the Edmundston police had been
asked to do a wellness check on Chantal
Moore on Thursday her family indigenous
leaders and Canada's indigenous Services
Minister want to know why the officer
who checked on her shot her and killed
her
I'm pissed I'm outraged there needs to
be a full accounting of of what has gone
on this is a pattern that keeps
repeating itself global Silas Brown is
in Edmundston New Brunswick looking for
answers it's been one day since Chantal
Moore was shot and killed by Edmundston
police inside her home and a growing
chorus of people are chanting for
justice and for some justice means
answers one finding out the truth to
honoring that truth and the third piece
giving life to that truth so that to me
is complete justice then a child myth
tribal council is calling for an
immediate independent investigation to
provide just that the 26 year old more
originally from British Columbia was
shot by an officer performing a wellness
check Edmundston police have handed the
investigation off to Quebec Spoleto but
for Mariah Charlson the incident speaks
to the need to better trained police in
de-escalation and trauma-informed
practices we don't want to see any more
of our women indigenous women men
anybody any human being we do not want
to see our people dying at the hands of
the police doing a health check
according to Lorraine Wittman the
president of the native women's
Association of Canada fear and distrust
is inherent in any encounter an
indigenous person has with the police
and that fear is within and I can
imagine that this young lady would have
felt that hour of the morning and a
police officer coming to the door and
knocking because the officer went in
alone and Edmundston police are not
equipped with body cameras
we may never know what happened but
mores family and her community will not
stop trying to find out and to find
justice Silas Brown Global News add
minced a New Brunswick now back to the
simmering anger in the United States
President Trump did nothing to quell it
today instead he hailed this as a good
day for George Floyd and a great great
day in terms of equality that is not how
millions of people see it Trump has
called for authorities to dominate the
streets as Jackson prosecco reports
there's growing concerns some police
officers are responding too harshly to
peaceful protesters in a nation on edge
mass protests are pushing Americans to
their limits in Buffalo New York a 75
year old man was shoved to the ground by
riot police he suffered a serious head
injury at first police claimed he
tripped they later suspended the
officers involved why why why was that
necessary
where was the threat it comes after a
week that saw Buffalo Police struck by a
car during protests and as the debate
rages over the proper use of force
nationwide in New York a delivery driver
was arrested for violating curfew
despite being exempt as an essential
worker and when police unleashed tear
gas and pepper spray balls on protesters
outside the White House Monday
officers brutalized an Australian TV
crew
oh whoa later claiming they failed to
clearly identify themselves as
journalists despite holding a camera you
have to dominate the streets you can't
let what's happening happen school
dominate the streets but president
continues to call for a heavy-handed
response from his perch behind the two
kilometres of new fencing that surround
the White House Trump even suggested
this is a positive moment for race
relations in America invoking the name
of George Floyd hopefully George is
looking down right now and saying
there's a great thing that's happening
for our country there's a great day for
him it's a great day for everybody
instead of discouraging marchers the
police response seems to have drawn
larger crowds in peaceful protest the
demands for accountability and reform
are growing louder it took a war to end
slavery and if it takes protests if it
takes people holding up signs if it
takes people coming out and just
petitioning for people like my life my
skin color my friends can color the
matter then that's a lot better than
here this weekend cities across America
are bracing for massive demonstrations
perhaps the largest to date a sign that
the death of George Floyd has triggered
the Great Awakening long sought by so
many tonight in Buffalo 57 members of
the city's riot squad have resigned on
mass to protest the disciplinary action
taken against their colleagues and back
here in Washington the feud continues
between the city's mayor and the
president inside the White House today
the mayor ordered city crews to come out
here to the two blocks leading up to the
White House and paint a black lives
matter mural in road paint the letters
are four lanes wide and span two city
blocks and the street directly in front
of the White House has been renamed
black lives matter Plaza
dawna tonight many of the troops that
were brought into this area in case they
were needed are in fact being sent back
home
right Jackson cross go in Washington
thank you there's some promising news
about the US economy and it's not what
analysts expected the US unemployment
rate dropped slightly in May to 13.3%
employers added 2.5 million jobs last
month more than half of the gains were
in restaurants and bars April marked the
biggest hit to the US labor market the
unemployment rates skyrocketed to a
record fourteen point seven percent even
though it dropped a bit in May the
jobless rate is still on par with what
it was during the Great Depression
there are also some slight positive
signs here in Canada Canada added two
hundred ninety thousand new jobs in May
that makes it the best month in history
but it happens to be after two of the
worst months ever and millions of people
are still out of work Mike Armstrong
reports the predictions were way off as
analysts waited for May's jobs figures
they expected the bleeding to continue
the average estimate was that Canada
would lose another 500,000 jobs instead
it went in the other direction
adding 290 thousand this is a pleasant
surprise to be sure you know we had a
sense that you know the big shot was
coming to an end but we didn't could be
ending so quickly
now the economy may not be shedding jobs
but the recovery is only just beginning
there's still a long way to go to get
anywhere near where things were pre
Kovan 19 over the years there are always
ups and downs some big some small and
maze new numbers are great record
breaking in fact but what happened in
March was devastating and was repeated
in April we've only regained about 10
percent of what was lost there's still a
crater there's a crater right it's deep
and it's massive and we're gonna have to
continue to claw our way out of it
in fact even as the economy added jobs
the unemployment rate went up more
people were looking for work and that
pushed Canada's unemployment rate to a
new all-time high thirteen point seven
percent that isn't entirely bad news
nearly a million people rushed back into
the market saying I want a job and
that's why
unemployment number went up but that
again to me is a good sign it says that
people now have the hope that they can
find a job as you know most of the job
gains were in Quebec about 80 percent
its first steps reopening were earlier
than most of the country the stats can
numbers are a snapshot of one week mid
month before most provinces had started
reopening June's figures could be
another very strong month my carbs from
Global News Montreal the numbers reveal
something else they show that two-thirds
of the new jobs went to men while women
are still bearing the brunt of the
impact from Kovac nineteen that's partly
because men are over-represented in
industries like manufacturing and
construction which are recovering faster
a University of Calgary economist
created this graph to show the
disproportionate impact the pandemic has
had on women
Canada's employment minister Carla
Quatro said today that a successful
recovery will involve a deliberate focus
on supporting women a Liberal MP from
Ontario is facing several criminal
charges after being arrested in April
police in Guelph Ontario say Marwan
tomorrow the Liberal MP for Kitchener
South Hessler has been charged with two
counts of assault one count a break and
enter and commit an indictable offense
and one count of criminal harassment the
charges are dated April 10th tomorrow
was elected to the House of Commons in
2015 a spokesperson for the Prime
Minister's Office told Global News it is
looking into the matter it's not clear
whether to borrow will be allowed to
stay in caucus a poignant tribute with
paddles coming up how the surfing
community is honoring George Floyd
the UK has reached a grim coronavirus
milestone more than 40,000 people have
now died there a kovat 19 that's the
second highest death toll after the u.s.
nearly two hundred and eighty five
thousand people have tested positive for
the virus in the UK that's up more than
1,600 from yesterday but the daily
number of new infections is beginning to
drop Brazil now has the third highest
number of deaths from kovat 19 almost
1,400 people were confirmed to have died
there on Thursday the most in a single
day in Brazil a total of more than
34,000 people are now known to have died
there of kovat 19 brazil's president has
played down the crisis and is trying to
force cities like Rio to reopen beaches
still ahead the struggle to pull the
plug on an alleged Canadian crime scheme
when a collision happens in Ottawa tow
trucks often race to the scene to get
the job many hookups are worth $1000 or
more in April charges were laid against
three police officers in relation to an
alleged kickback scheme and now a global
news investigation has discovered
insiders allege the problem is much more
widespread Mike look at or reports
Ottawa's tow truck industry has been
called the Wild West by those who work
in it little to no regulation it's often
up to police officers at crash scenes to
play referee between competing tow
drivers one insider tells Global News
some drivers have an unfair advantage
known as cop connects where a police
officer will give them the job in
exchange for up to five hundred dollars
protecting his identity because this
whistleblower fears he will be targeted
for peeling back the curtain on
corruption in the industry and he knows
it so well because he says he too paid
off a police officer to get toes money
motorcycles cars
not just for oxygen just for information
sometimes Global News has spoken to a
number of drivers who say that's just
how the industry works three Ottawa
police officers and three civilians are
facing charges including breach of trust
and fraud from an RCMP investigation
into allegations of a kickback scheme
involving police officers and tow truck
drivers when those charges were first
laid in April Ottawa police chief Peter
slowly called the charges very serious
but added that they do not reflect the
overall integrity of o-p-s members last
month police north of Toronto arrested
20 people and laid hundreds of organized
crime related charges after an
investigation into ongoing tow truck
turf wars a similar battle could be
brewing in the capital Ottawa Police
arson squad is investigating a fire at a
toe
yard in late May a number of vehicles
were destroyed that is bad enough that I
lost my business
Jorge Barad says he had to get out of
towing because he was constantly being
told to leave crash scenes my police
officers who he says with handpicking
tow truck drivers who showed up
if the police tells you to go with this
tow company as opposed to this tow
company generally speaking you're gonna
go with the police's recommendation
Mourad tried to create a towing
Association for Ottawa two years ago
with set fees for services to help stop
the so-called favoritism and to protect
consumers from price gouging brad says
there was little support from City Hall
but that could be changing Ottawa City
Council announced online consultations
on possible regulations for the tow
truck industry we've received complaints
over the years of strong-arm tactics and
outrageous prices that that people have
had to pay because they feel they have
no other choice
the hope is regulations will level the
playing field and prevent tow truck
drivers from trying to get every
advantage possible Mike Lou creature
Global News Ottawa
next the Canadian girl with a voice
beyond her years
[Applause]
it's almost impossible to believe but
this girl is just ten years old her name
is Roberta Battaglia she's from Toronto
and she left the judges on America's Got
Talent in awe she's saying the
oscar-winning song from a star is born
[Applause]
[Music]
in all the good times
well myself
shut your eyes and all the bad tums up
here myself Italia is now off to the
semi-final live show she says she
started singing with her dad when she
was 3 and her dream was always to be on
America's Got Talent
now a former judge on that show
Gabrielle Union has filed a
discrimination complaint against the
producers she claims she was fired for
refusing to stay silent about racist and
sexist behavior on the set that is
global national for this Friday I'm
Donna Friesen we leave you tonight with
images of the thousands of surfers
taking part in a worldwide paddle out
surfers sat in solidarity with black
lives matter thanks for watching take
care of yourselves bye bye
[Music]